perfecto
profesora de santiago pérez qué balance
haría usted de la actuación de canadá
frente a la pandemia
tomando en cuenta cuál ha sido su
estrategia ante la misma estrategia del
país me refiero cuál es el estado de
situación actual
creo que siempre es un poco injusto
comparar el país contra país pero
tomando eso en cuenta si vemos cómo
reaccionó canadá ante la pandemia y
observamos cómo reaccionaron otros
países de nuevo con realidades distintas
no cada uno pero creo que canadá y yo
creo que yo podría decir el balance no
ha sido malo y creo que tienen un
sistema de salud robusto
por lo menos es un sistema que podemos
decir único pese a que cada provincia
tiene su propio manejo pero comparando
con con méxico por ejemplo que realmente
le ha ido terrible y es porque o sea
tienen un sistema de salud roto en cinco
diferentes sistemas entonces siempre
digo es esto de la pandemia es como un
carro que va en la carretera y se
accidenta sí pero ese carro resulta que
no
una placa
no tenga en la llanta de refacción y no
tenía papeles y era además un carro
prestado y el dueño no está en fin
y eso sería mexicano ante la pandemia
canadá sería un carro que igual se
accidente mismo accidente pero tiene
seguro tiene todas sus placas en orden
tiene los papeles en orden el dueño está
esté ahí presente
todo está en orden entonces eso permite
reaccionar de manera adecuada claro eso
no hace que lo salve completamente sí
creo que hubo muchos errores
creo que se reaccionó de manera muy
lenta creo que se tomaron
pues se confiaron un poco quizás la
gente no pensó que fuera a llegar tan
tan fuerte y también bueno jugaron en la
balanza cuestiones económicas cuestiones
sociales y entonces no pudo canadá
lograr lo que logró australia por
ejemplo lo que logró nueva zelanda
el famoso co beats cero absoluto algunas
provincias de canadá lo lograron lo
logran muy bien cabe mencionar que el
canadá atlántico tiene muy poca
población y tiene muy poca migración
turística y comercial entonces también
quizás habría que admitir es un poco más
fácil para ellos cerrar completamente y
lograr ese cómic ser o no provincias
comentario la más poblada de todo canadá
pues te es normal que no puedan cerrar
completamente es normal que tengan
digamos dificultades para pues proveer a
toda su población de de vacunas de
manera rápida
entonces es normal tampoco estoy
juzgando a los gobiernos de las
diferentes provincias creo que insisto
tenían un sistema de salud robusto
establecido con reglas muy claras y
entonces pues reaccionaron de manera no
con las herramientas que tenían pero
esta pandemia se ha visto en todos los
países incluyendo francia por ejemplo
que sería otro ejemplo de primer mundo
con un sistema de seguridad social muy
bien puesto pero que le está yendo
horrible horrible y también pues la
población ya se empieza a desgastar y
alcanzar y entonces ya llevamos más de
un año y esta situación no avanza no
pero creo que para terminar mi
comentario hay luz al final del túnel
están las vacunas que están llegando
este pues cada vez más proceso desde
hace ya varios días se habla de una
tercera ola de contagios
en algunos casos está ya claramente en
marcha tanto aquí en canadá como en
otros países y se dice también que está
tercera ola sería supuestamente más
agresiva que las anteriores etc está de
acuerdo porque sería así y en todo caso
sí claro si vemos las curvas como
estuvieron la figura empezamos la
segunda ola en más o menos septiembre de
octubre hubo una pequeña aceleración
después del día de acción de gracias y
después obviamente navidad año nuevo
pues despegó no para más o menos el 26
de diciembre que fue el día del del
cierre no este desde por lo menos de
ontario
teníamos 2.500 casos por día más o menos
para esta tercera ola llegamos perdón y
recapituló para llegar a esos 2.500
entonces pasó desde septiembre octubre
nueve como tres meses para lograr ese
2500 y aquí ahorita y llegamos a 2500 en
menos de 30 días entonces se ve
claramente como la subida de esta
tercera ola es impresionantemente más
abrupta mucho más rápido y eso habla del
número de contagios mucho mayor una
fuerza mucho mayor y por ende va a tener
mucho más inercia todas las acciones que
hagamos hoy van vamos a ver el resultado
hasta dos a tres semanas después no y
quizás esta ola todavía se tarde un poco
más por por esa inercia que tiene esa
fuerza de contagio que tiene también
tiene diferencias otras diferencias esta
tercera ola
hemos visto muchas más personas
hospitalizadas y de esas mucho mayor
proporción está en terapia intensiva las
edades han cambiado al son personas más
jóvenes que en la segunda y en la
primera bola
cabe mencionar obviamente otros factores
por ejemplo las personas adultas mayores
están vacunadas no un gran porcentaje de
ellas está aquí en canadá están ya
vacunadas y eso ayuda mucho a que no se
infecten además están protegidas la
mayor parte no salen o están en estas
casas de retiro no este entonces
obviamente pues están más protegidos
entonces todo esto hace que los que se
infecten pues son personas jóvenes la la
la segunda ola también tenía personas
jóvenes
estas personas siempre estaban
asintomáticas y ahora claramente no
solamente tienen síntomas sino que esos
síntomas los llevan al hospital entonces
es una tercera ola más con más contagios
con estos contagios es entre personas
más jóvenes que tienen más síntomas que
los lleva a terapia intensiva pero la
buena noticia es que esas personas no
parecen morir
tanto como en la segunda ola es la
mortalidad no ha seguido pero es un
juego muy peligroso no nos podemos
confiar es decir si no hay mortalidad
entonces no hay problema porque porque
si no se mueren porque son jóvenes no
tienen comorbilidades y aguantan más
pero requieren muchos cuidados de
terapia intensiva si la terapia
intensiva empieza a fallar porque hay
demasiados y ya no alcanzan los cuidados
entonces vamos a empezar a ver un
incremento en la mortalidad
algunos especialistas en salud e
investigadores en el área proponen abrir
el abanico de vacunación con la primera
dosis y abarcar a una población más
extensa postergando la segunda
inoculación sostienen que esto
permitiría tener más gente vacunada al
menos con una de las dosis que ha
demostrado ser efectiva un alto a un
alto nivel de efectividad cercano en
algunos casos al 80% usted está de
acuerdo con esta postura si totalmente
es mucho mejor tener a toda la población
oa la mayoría de la población vacunada
con una dosis que al 30% con dos dosis
es mucho mejor obtener en efecto como lo
menciono facer público el 80% de
protección con la primera dosis
vaya entonces si tenemos por lo menos
esa primera dosis vamos a tener a la
mayor parte de las personas protegidas
en lo que esperamos la segunda dosis eso
no significa que no se debe aplicar la
segunda dosis simplemente que el
aplazarla nos da nos permite este
ofrecerle la vacuna esa primera dosis a
más personas y entonces podemos ver ese
esa baja de infecciones no
una de las críticas que se le hace en la
estrategia canadiense es el de la demora
en vacunar a la población y más allá de
eso que es un condicionante que ha
afectado no solamente a canadá sino
prácticamente a todas las naciones en el
planeta lo que se llama la atención es
que siendo canadá un país desarrollado y
con una experiencia en el nivel de la
investigación científica muy extensa no
cuente aún con una vacuna pero no es
tampoco este un caso exclusivo de este
país cuáles son las principales
dificultades que enfrenta una nación en
este caso desarrollada como canadá para
contar con una vacuna propia en este
caso
es el resultado de decisiones pasadas no
invirtieron en en industria para generar
su propia vacuna y fue una decisión
tomada en tiempos en donde no había
pandemia obviamente y pues no no podían
saber que iba haber una pandemia todo un
poco el mundo científico no nos
esperábamos algún día la pandemia yo
llevo diez años trabajando en eso y aún
así me agarró por sorpresa no esté pero
entonces los gobiernos tampoco es
sorprendente que los haya tomado por
sorpresa y las decisiones que tomaron
años atrás en no invertir en el
desarrollo de vacunas dijeron bueno pues
vamos mejor las compramos y que alguien
más las hagan siempre este tipo de
inversiones pues es una apuesta al
futuro y pues tienen los gobiernos no
los disculpo pero tampoco los acuso son
decisiones muy difíciles de tomar este
lo que uno apuesta pues es gastar ese
dinero por algo que quizás vendrá a
futuro pero ahorita tengo este algún
gobierno pues tiene problemas distintos
en cuanto a si invertimos en este
hidrocarburos o en este energías
sustentables en fin no hay tantos
problemas todo el tiempo que con los
cuales hay que lidiar que bueno pues
tomaron esa decisión de no invertir en
la contras ahorita ahorita ya es muy
tarde ahorita ya creo que han empezado a
tratar de generar los recursos para
poder generar la vacuna pero pues ya la
pandemia ya estamos muy avanzados el
proceso al huti no hablaba de la
posibilidad de que en el marco de esta
tercera ola de contagios un mayor número
de jóvenes llegue a requerir cuidados de
salud e incluso de cuidados intensivos
pues son los otros riesgos que
enfrentamos a partir de este momento en
el marco de esta pandemia
el problema es por ejemplo que se está
ocupando distrayendo todos los servicios
de salud en kobe y entonces ahorita para
poder hacer frente a todo esto se han
detenido por ejemplo todas las cirugías
programadas y toda la atención de los
pacientes crónicos para poder dirigir
recursos humanos hacia la atención de
pacientes con vida y esto genera un
problema muy fuerte
a mediano y largo plazo es decir que va
a aumentar muy seguramente las
complicaciones crónicas de estos
pacientes por ejemplo pacientes con
enfermedad cardiovascular con
enfermedades reumáticas
en fin y entonces es posible que
lleguemos a ver un aumento de la
mortalidad ahora no por covite sino
indirectamente por la falta de la
atención entonces este es uno de los
peligros creo a los cuales nos vamos a
tener que enfrentar más y esto aunado a
todos los problemas de crisis económicas
que se vienen por estos este
órdenes de quedarse en casa y encierros
en donde están cerrando comercios
pequeños y demás
y entonces la actividad económica va a
ser muy difícil pues
y además usted hablaba no solamente de
el riesgo sanitario en el sentido de
tener más pacientes hablaba de su
experiencia
la investigación de esta pandemia decía
que aún teniendo una década de
experiencia en investigación en ese
campo lo tomó por sorpresa que se debe
cambiar que se debe hacer para prevenir
una futura pandemia y no encontrarse en
alguna situación de asfixia en la que
nos encontramos en este momento hablo en
el plano global cierto claro a mí lo que
digamos mi participación en la
investigación en cuanto a prepararse
para la pandemia fue generar grupos de
colaboración para en caso de una
pandemia poder generar investigación
rápidamente y eso fue gracias a mi
mentor el doctor guillermo ruiz palacios
en en méxico y generó esa colaboración
con los en agen en eeuu y de hecho no me
sorprendió que durante esta pandemia
generaron artículos muy importantes que
se publicaron en new england journal of
medicine' por ejemplo por citar algunos
y generar un conocimiento muy
rápidamente porque estaban listos pero
creo que es un error el prepararse desde
el punto de vista científico únicamente
creo que la sociedad en general tiene
que prepararse para la siguiente en
pandemia porque habrá otra con otro
virus quizás más problemático aún y lo
que me agarró por sorpresa es es ver por
ejemplo yo yo no no había percibido que
mi hija no iba a poder ir a la escuela
yo no había no me había percatado que él
él superó algunas tiendas iban a estar
cerradas no me había percatado que los
restaurantes iban a cerrar y no es que
el restaurante sea importante pero es
una actividad económica entonces pues si
van a perder trabajos los meseros y los
chef y los dueños de los restaurantes y
de ahí es una bola de nieve que yo no
había para nada previsto pero creo que
ahorita es el momento para que los
gobiernos entiendan esto y aprendan la
lección y se preparen para la siguiente
pandemia aunque tomes 100 años pero va a
requerir un cambio en la sociedad
cuantas veces yo en particularmente en
méxico y creo que canadá es igual de
eeuu es peor éste cuántas veces no
fuimos al trabajo enfermos
no esté ahí tengo gripe pero bueno me
tomo un profe no una aspirina lo que sea
y vamos a trabajar no hay cuántas veces
no criticamos incluso a nuestros
compañeros sea si se siente mal y no
quiso venir a trabajar que flojo no esté
y ahorita en pandemia todo el mundo es
como no si estás enfermo no vengas
porque nos vas a contagiar es muy
importante que no vengas incluso hay un
médico creo que en canadá que perdió su
licencia porque vio pacientes y estaba
enfermo entonces es el cambio cultural
tiene que cambiar tenemos que permitir
que la gente pueda pedir permiso y no
perder su trabajo por ello o no perder
el día de paga también los trabajadores
esenciales y muchas veces los que
trabajan y ganan por día de trabajo no
pueden pedir permisos porque si no no
les pagan ese día y eso ha sido una
discusión terrible este y eso y el
modelo económico tiene que cambiar
ahorita se sale
de la ciencia pura de esta situación y
abarca pues cuestiones económicas y
sociales que creo que hay que tomar en
cuenta necesitamos colaborar científicos
economistas políticos etcétera y
antropólogos para prepararnos para el
futuro pero cambiando la sociedad por
último cuando comenzó la pandemia la
organización mundial de la salud hablaba
de otro problema que enfrentábamos que
era el de la info de emi a ese conjunto
de informaciones falsas y
malintencionadas que desinforman a la
población y uno de los efectos de esa
desinformación ha sido en algunos casos
convencerían por casos reforzar las
opiniones de personas que dudan de la
necesidad de vacunarse qué mensaje les
enviaré usted de esas personas
es ha sido de las peores experiencias
para mí en esta pandemia de las más
frustrantes porque el ver gente morir el
ver gente sufrir pues es lo que yo hago
y hecho desde que empecé a ser médico y
antes de la pandemia pues no es con lo
que yo pues uno nunca se acostumbra al
sufrimiento pero me refiero a que pues
ese era mi trabajo pero lidiar contra la
desinformación y frustrarme porque la
gente le crea más a un vídeo de youtube
o un vídeo que circula en whatsapp
a hechos científicos es algo terrible
he vivido he perdido amigos he discutido
con familiares que me han gritado en el
whatsapp
por culpa de esta desinformación y por
qué o tratar de corregirlos y ha sido
desde medicamentos este que nos sirven
[Música]
y bueno con las vacunas ha sido
realmente muy frustrante entonces
realmente yo si quisiera es muy
importante que cuando reciban una
información traten de buscar la fuente
desinformación la gente lee los
titulares no los títulos o ve el vídeo y
no se cuestiona será cierto me estarán
engañando no no se cuestiona de dónde
viene quién es la persona que está
hablando no y muchas veces el problema
es quién se presenta en el vídeo dice yo
soy médico y soy intensivista y trabajo
en tal parte ok y luego mezcla verdades
esa es la desinformación más peligrosa
mezcla verdades no hay dice bueno es que
hay estos datos y todo eso es verdad
pero luego malinterpreta y empieza a
mezclar
datos que no son ciertos que no tienen
ningún fundamento pero ahí es es muy
engañoso entonces yo diría
no hay habría que desconfiar
inmediatamente de cualquier vídeo que
está circulando en whatsapp y en youtube
primero hay que irse a las fuentes
oficiales a la oms a la cdc a la
secretaria de salud o al ministerio de
salud de su gobierno local regional o
nacional y ver si esa información es
compatible pues con la que está
mostrando x vídeo x información que está
recibiendo las vacunas realmente si
funcionan y es lo único que nos va a
sacar adelante de esta pandemia es lo
único que va a hacer que nuestros hijos
regresen a la escuela que recuperemos
los trabajos que recuperemos la
actividad económica y que logremos
abrazarnos y vernos de nuevo con
nuestros adultos mayores es esa es la la
luz al final del túnel ya la tenemos
ahora es cuestión además de aplicársela
al hombro de cada uno
de los habitantes de los diferentes
países si no se la quieren aplicar no va
a ser obligatorio pero si muy poca gente
se le aplica no va a servir de nada la
vacuna porque va a proteger a una
persona pero todos los demás van a estar
en peligro pero realmente sí yo imploro
a la gente que nos hagan caso a los que
nos dedicamos a eso lo único que
queremos es ayudar no tenemos ninguna
agenda escondida en donde queramos
dominar al mundo
o ganar más dinero lo que queremos es de
verdad regresar a un estado normal y las
vacunas es el camino
profesor santiago pérez de la
universidad de queens en ontario muchas
gracias por esta entrevista perdón con
radio canadá internacional
es un placer y este pues qué gusto hacer
esta entrevista en español